Your time starts
now. Is Yahweh the most high God? Yeah,
so when you're referring to Yahweh, the
ineffable creator, the father of the
son, then yeah, he's the most high God.
Is Is Jesus Yahweh? Jesus is Yahweh in
the lesser sense, yeah. Jesus is Yahweh
in the lesser sense. Nice. Man, thank
you so much. So, what makes you believe
Muhammad received revelation over Paul
receiving revelation?
>> Cuz Paul's a liar. Okay, so what makes
you think he lied about his him
receiving revelation? Uh because Why?
>> Because of what he received based upon
your text and what the disciples
believed was contrary. All right, so
just to be clear, you're saying because
Paul and what he's supposedly received
is contrary to what the apostles have,
then that would make Paul a liar.
>> Yes. Okay, so for somebody to be a true
messenger, to have credibility, they
would have to be in line with the
apostles, is that correct?
>> Yes. Okay. Was Muhammad in line with the
apostles? Please, don't do that
nonsense. That's what we're doing. Don't
do that nonsense. Is no Is no double
standards.
>> Don't do that nonsense.
>> No double standards. No, the thing is,
you see, we're talking about your text.
We're talking about both. I'm I'm not
playing this game. I don't answer
questions to Christians until you
demonstrate you understand English,
comprehend it, utilize it. The point
here is this, you made so many claims
about Paul which went unchallenged.
>> I'm sorry, your grace. Forgive my
insolence. Unfortunately, we do have I'm
going to play Battle of Badr tonight.
And you have a triangle square when you
admitted it is an impossible existence.
Well, let's see. Let's see. Let's see.
I got you. What shape is this?
Triangle. That is a square. This is a
square?
>> Yes. Okay. What shape is in the square?
>> Triangle.
Wait.
So, with your position, can there be a
square triangle? That would be one shape
that is a square triangle, one shape,
right?
I I know. That's what I'm saying. So,
I'm I'm demonstrating to you
If you're If you're going to listen
You're nervous now. You're panicking.
Now you're panicking now. Now you're
panicking. You're asking is there one
shape that can be both a triangle and a
square at the same time? Right, and the
answer is no. My position is is not that
Jesus has one nature that is mixed with
human and divine. My argument is My
position is that Jesus has two natures,
one divine, one human, and they're
united in the person. They don't
intermingle. They're not mixed. He wants
to see that in Mark 13:32, the word
know, the word oiden, can mean to tell
something or declare something, right?
So, I'mma show him this really quick.
It's crazy, y'all. Very clearly, this is
It says, "Be aware."
"Behold." "X can not tell."
"Not tell." Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. "Not tell." It says
"Not tell." Oh my gosh. Ask him. Keep
reading. Keep reading. Keep reading.
"Consider." Yeah. "Have." "Know."
"Look." "Perceive." "See." "Be sure."
"Tell."
>> [screaming]
>> Wait a minute.
You got cooked. You got cooked.
You got cooked. You got cooked. Why did
the question trust me then?
The question is
The question
The question is, why did he go to all
the other words
and only choose the term
But
Now, I'm asking a simple question. The
Antichrist, when he comes back and he
comes and says, "I am God." Would the
Christians or the Muslims fall for his
trap? The Muslims. The Muslims. No, your
Muhammad says the Muslims will fall for
it. What are you talking about?
>> I know that.
>> According to Muhammad
>> It's the Muslims that will be confused
about the Dajjal. Muhammad doesn't say
that you'll be deceived by his by his
powers and the miracles that he does. He
says, "So that you don't get the man,
the Dajjal, the Antichrist is a man,
confused with Allah, which I don't know
how you'll do it because Allah's not a
man, right?"
Just so that you don't get confused, the
Antichrist with Allah, he's hen-toed,
he's curly-haired, he's short, but just
know that your Lord is not one-eyed.
He's one-eyed, but Allah, he's not
one-eyed. That's how you can tell the
difference. Okay.
>> So, they're virtually identical. They're
identical. You see where this is coming
from? Because they believe
The Quran is very clear here. If you are
in doubt, Muhammad, do this. Go to the
people who've been reading the scripture
before you. Show me anywhere in the
Quran where where where Allah tells
Muhammad, "If you're in doubt about that
which we have revealed to you, do
something else." Yeah, I I can pull up
you some verses. All right, go ahead.
I'm waiting. No, but while I'm pointing
that out or while I'm pulling that up,
can you explain to me 2 hours later. So,
Avery, here's a simple question. Has to
do with my opening statement.
>> Are you going to get the verse? Oh, you
You want that? Okay. You Surah
Al-Anbiya, 21:7. And we did not send
before you except men to whom we
revealed. So, ask the people of
knowledge if you do not know. Whoa.
Yeah, so that's 21:7. Whoa, blew your
mind, right? And then 16:43.
And we did not send before you except
men to whom we revealed our message. So,
ask the people of knowledge if you do
not know. Ahl
al-dhikr. Ahl al-dhikr. That's what
Exactly. What What is that word? What
does that mean? It's people of
knowledge, people of remembrance. Yeah,
it can be translated. The reminder. Who
are they? Who are the people of the
reminder? And Muhammad, if If you don't
know, where are they supposed to go? To
the people of the reminder. Who are
they? People of knowledge.
>> Who are they? People of knowledge.
People of knowledge. It could It could
It could be Christians. Yeah, it could
be Christians.
>> Thank you so much. But so this is not a
god This is My point is the point that
I'm bringing you.
Daniel, you went to verses that
literally
says to come to us if you don't know.
Come to us. You're literally proving my
point. That the verifier of the Quran,
the determining truth of the Quran, is
us. You got to come to us.
Even when you talk about That's why I
had you say what the what the word is in
in the Arabic. It's al-dhikr, the people
of the reminder. That's us. That's our
book. So, you need to come to us if you
do not know. So, you gave me two other
verses that prove my point that we are
the judge, our scripture is the judge of
the Quran, and if the Quran is out of
line with it, then guess what? The Quran
is [clears throat] false. Dilemma. Just
Just really quick, too. I want to I need
to put this up here, guys. Um we have a
We have a audience. We have a audience
here. The Christians right now. That's
That's That's us.
Another stream permeating through the
Hey, Hamza. Hey, Yanni. Hey, guys. Oh,
wow.
>> [laughter]
>> Hey. Hey, why doesn't Hamza just jump
in, man?
I'm trying to understand the Hey, can't
can't Hamza just [laughter] jump in,
man?
Hey.
Hey, [laughter] how does Hamza get in?
Come on.
our show. [laughter] So, come here. You
want to talk about it, so come here.
Just Hamza to So, you guys know, you
guys have an official invite.
Come on up, guys.
They're
They're leeching off
your stream. Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Yo,
you got You guys are more than welcome
You guys are more than welcome to come
through. [laughter]
They're They're leeching. We saw how he
kicked him out when he got you by the
neck.
We clipped it. Thank you for that. Thank
you for that.
>> [laughter]
>> They thought they were just going to
expose us as hiding away. No, we're I'm
still here in the maverick. By the way,
isn't that isn't that really, really
weird? Like we have We're in the middle
of a stream and they start responding
[laughter] to our stream and we say,
"Hey, if you're responding to our
stream, just come over and respond to
us." No, you come over to ours, which is
leeching off yours. [laughter] Isn't
this
Isn't this what Islam always does? It
takes what other people are have come up
with and then says, "Haha, this is ours
now." Hey, look, there's a There's a
combo. A bunch of pagans are around it.
Let's take that for ourselves. Hey,
Hagia Sophia over there. What a
beautiful church. Let's take that for
ourselves. Oh, look at this lovely
temple now. We'll take that for
ourselves. And here you are trying to
take the live stream, the latest slap in
the face. We're not having it. They They
do this at Speakers' Corner, weirdly
enough. Like obviously not on live
streams cuz it's in person. But now, if
they have a debate that goes sour, they
want to split off and basically have
their own corner where they'll have like
a deity like any of those guys trying to
give the Islamic answer privately, away
from Christians, away from non-Muslims,
because the answer won't survive
scrutiny.
So, they They have to do it privately.
And I think that's basically the online
version of what that is. They're just
They're having their own sort of Muslim
get-together where they can privately
try and, you know, massage people's
egos, give them a little bit of a
psychological uplift. It's a Yeah, it's
[laughter] a therapy session. It's a
Muslim therapy session. That's basically
what It's okay, guys. It's okay. Our
Our book doesn't Our book doesn't affirm
their scriptures. Trust us.
>> [laughter]
>> Sit on the couch and